[Music]
[Music]
the Black Death is an epidemic on an
unimaginable scale which swept across
Europe in the mid 14th century killing
we now believe and the record is very
good up to half of the population one in
two of the population in the space of
seven years it's caused by a bacterium
which is called Yersinia pestis the
bacterium evolved actually from a
harmless non pathogenic bacterium that
normally lives in the soil but the
pathogenic yes in the air pest is is
spread by fleas which in turn I spread
by rats it's believed that the rats
moved around on ships and as part of
trades and the time in medieval Europe
but more recently there have been
outbreaks of the plague in North America
and South America for example so it's
very much although we think of the
plague as something that happened a long
time ago and so decimated the European
populations then it is still it's still
very much an ongoing concern and it's a
very important pathogen today the
authors and had access to teeth and
bones from East Smithfield's burial
ground here in London the scale of
deaths is enormous as an Italian
chronicler said at the time the living
was scarcely able to bury the dead so
the places like Smithfield was set up at
very short notice
just in order to get rid of the of the
bodies and to have the funerals that
were required in a Christian community
using techniques to sequence and analyze
ancient DNA they were able to
reconstruct the ancient genome obviously
near pestis the surprising thing that
emerges from this analysis is the fact
that the genomes of medieval yesenia
pestis and those of existing strains are
really remarkably similar and yet the
plague in
was so severe and the infections today
are much less severe by comparison what
accounts for this difference does not
really lie in the genome of the pathogen
but my must lie somewhere else and
amongst the suggestions that the authors
propose for example climatic changes
social changes to do with the way we
humans live but also our own immunity in
the interim between the middle ages and
now we would have been exposed to
different pathogens which perhaps has
augmented our immunity and allows us to
fight yesenia pestis infections better
in addition to probing into the genetic
basis of what made the bacterium so
infectious and the time allowed the
authors to look at the evolution of the
existing strains and and one of the
surprising things they find is that all
of the strains that are present in the
world today originate from those strains
that were around in medieval Europe in
the middle of 14th century paradoxically
society was able to cope much better in
the 14th century with deaths on this
horrendous scale than we would be able
to cope today and this is primarily
because people were to a degree
self-sufficient and independent whereas
today we have such complex
interconnections that deaths on anything
like that scale would cause complete
chaos it's interesting to consider
whether your senior pastors will return
in force in a similar way to what we
experienced in in the Middle Ages it's
really very difficult to say considering
that today we respond humans respond to
the infection much better than in that
time it's probably not very likely but
one thing to bear in mind of course is
that there might be other infections
that arise new pathogens that arise
evolve indeed bacteria that acquire
pathogenicity in a similar way that yes
senior pest is acquired from its
predecessor which was in fact a
free-living known pathogenic
completely benign soil bacterium
ooh 30 shut up on day to day lead us
into
[Music]